welcome to this video five-minute chess
against Billy but believe but I guess
where I'm from Spain he not decided yet
on a line let's see what he's doing e 66
what may be going for for the fianchetto
he wants to play a king's indian set up
going for this double fianchetto let's
see maybe five now so it's very often
play d 5 de 594 know okay okay let's
gain some space that's a yeah and that's
interesting up is going to this square
and we have and there's a very similar
line of course the the panel variation
in the fianchetto king's indian but here
i don't have a knight on c3 that's um
that's a difference really let's um
let's see the difference is that i have
fun kabbard on that have covered c4
quite reliably let's see i'd like to
play before of course maybe prepare that
with okie one later
yeah this Bishop will go to see three
anyway move like before it's not helping
and much I mean the night still stays
off side and before I would also release
pressure of the c-4 pond okay so now
let's let's grab space in the center you
are taken with the sea porn well I guess
that's still the right decision the
night only five stays outside yeah you
might put it on d3m okay i guess i
should prevent that
I don't have a clear active plenty ER i
mean i can always point to the fact that
the night is off-site but it's not it's
not like I have a very direct attacking
idea this I think is helpful for me
exchanging the bishops getting the Queen
to see 3 yeah the problem of this night
on on a hive is that okay he is now
closing closing this if I give this
check this Queen f6 maybe I should
threaten g4 here night h4 this Queen f6
know
also there's also a three interesting
yeah let's do that that's in fact
interesting try to to use the position
of the nice directly threatening to take
a black Queen a three maybe if you would
recapture with the porn i have the d4
square for the night yeah that's that's
quite problematic now for him don't
really see a great move takes Queen
takes just wins the apron or takes ok
that's also very problematic attique now
what is he doing he takes with the point
i have 94 that's strategically terrible
and T I have Queen a three or queen c3
its boughs interesting Quincy 3 is
trying to use this this pin I think this
is even stronger he really has problems
now to move simply threatening I mean he
was the King for example I can take a
five and take f6 and he has really big
problems to untie himself there's also
stuff like 95 and then G 494 one night
h2 intending g-form winning material
yeah more than more than one good good
continuation ok so what now is g4g fight
is what I'd like to get in so I can do
the CI a--
it takes takes Bishop takes Knight d4
and like is collapsing on them on the
knight on f6
the a bishop takes 94 and I will win
have 60 yeah now I can I can take a five
I can not quite sure why should I just
take yeah then there's f3 hanging up
that's a problem actually
isn't this so clear Knight f6 queen of 6
a-5 Bishop f3 that's not a winner
amazing hope that this wins at least
with night h7 coming really remarkable
maybe 90 for the move him
gen want to miss him
would be three maybe time warning
huh can give this check out this looks
very very shaky probably has something
Karen check check Carrie of course
that's not what I what I was dreaming
off check
please I'm not meet it at least I am not
mated can I give the chick I mean look a
seven attending this or maybe check the
room it's got what six seconds that's
that's really helpful black for a fake
smile Wow yeah I really made it more
difficult than necessary at it the
sometimes happens if you ignore the keep
it simple were in Queen a3 was very
simple just just grabbing here with the
overwhelming position okay this is even
better probably but I am mad that it
still wins now night h2 is winning not
this one okay that's actually not very
difficult yeah what didn't I see that
the point is that if he now takes here
yeah after this this is hanging with the
check if he takes about the king that's
a very easy win actually and here it is
histo a total mess yeah after after this
fancy looking move I'm lost I'm lost
amazing with rupee 3m rupee three is
winning from the black yeah check yeah
the problem is that yes this means Wow
okay with this coming with check or this
year like threatening everything okay
yeah this this would have been winning
even for black
okay this is just total total crapshoot
with this time Pusha page 3 is winning
again t I'm here why this gigantic check
yeah okay well the time decided at the
end I was simply not seeing this this
move Knight h2 in this position which
would have been the the logical end of
the game with wide winning a piece but I
simply fail to see it okay thanks for
watching